foreign
sex lives of college girls Renee rep I'm
Rick Carr Pauline chalamet and Alia
Chanel Scott
um are okay ladies uh your characters on
the show have had their Fair shares of
Adventures in dating I'd love to get
some hot takes in a game of red flag
yellow flag green flag
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll read a detail about a hypothetical
date and you hold up the flag as you see
fit all right read off I mean I think
this is self-explanatory obviously no
thank you heck yeah and gee gosh there's
some gray areas in there okay all right
question number one you get to the date
and you find out that they're four
inches shorter than their dating profile
says oh
don't lie oh wait then their profile
said yeah like they lied I know that was
the caveat because I love it I love a
shorter man but I guess it's like yeah
what are you what are you insecure about
like they're my insecure I feel bad I
don't like a liar I
I
okay
we don't like a liar yeah that I don't
like starting off on that foot a guy
texted me on a dating app and told me
this elaborate story of how he lived
above a cobbler and the smell of leather
is so nostalgic for him and I said
that's a really cool story and he goes I
made it all up I was like block yeah
like you're done okay all right then the
profile says and that's a red flag yeah
yeah but you know what maybe they're
really insecure about it right but
aren't we all you know what I mean like
honesty is all we ask for yeah you're
right you're right you're right like if
I show up I'm honesty I'll be honest too
all right well if your date loves to
clap when the plane lands
oh ironic
[Applause]
that would do it like you're like ironic
like I'm gonna start the clap and I'm
like don't start the Clapping they're
like I'm gonna start the clap then I'm
like that's cute like that's fun but if
you're just like genuinely like clapping
because the plane landed yeah so no I
think it's cute I'm on board I think
it's cute pun intended on board
something about the enthusiasm is gonna
do it for me every time
[Applause]
your date belches loudly on the first
outing together absolutely not goodbye
really you would not want to date me
[Applause]
you show up and your date is in a fedora
yeah
interesting yeah you're gonna have to go
I don't know it could be cute and it
could be weird okay yeah I would have to
ask more questions yeah yeah right we
need contact yeah
[Applause]
Renee wants one on a date can I say this
really wants to date with someone and
the doctor was like how'd the day goes
like I thought they were great
um didn't love the outfit so I don't
think it's gonna
wait in my defense in my defense
she's amazing but the outfit was
something that was
distracting to a point that I was like
interesting I don't know that I should
be sitting here like I just was like I
don't think our personalities go
together you know what I mean but you
know once there's a point where no one
has any clothes on and then and then so
true and an amazing point which is why
I've powered through you did okay
I love the naked party it's so fun okay
your date tells that uh your date tells
you they keep the water running uh while
brushing their teeth
I'm gonna give it a yellow it's gonna be
a yellow for me because I think it can
be a teachable moment Evolution yeah
it's important it's been a little bit of
parenting for the person that you're
dating and it's immediately yeah no we
are in 2022 we're not in 2002 anymore
now we know that we should turn the
water off yeah but a lot of men take a
long time to get out of their diapers
metaphorically speaking and by the way a
huge part of why I sometimes do get
turned off to younger love stories is
I'm like I've already learned these
things and I don't want a man well
actually I I don't want to be a mommy or
a bit you know I don't want a baby I
want a grown up yeah but you know they
may have been raised in a different way
they may have not that one I feel like I
could do this it could go either way
they're way bigger fish to fry in the uh
exactly
just say hey you know what I don't know
if you know well that already sounds
patronizing but
baby how about if you turn the water off
while you brush your teeth I'll give you
something that makes it worthwhile
um hot for some reason I don't like that
[Applause]
what would you say
turn the water off
instead again
that's why I like you so much in your
character on your show you have a
sureness of yourself there's a
confidence that seeps through that's
really incredible yeah cool see I've got
to figure out some pithy thing and
you're just like no
yeah like the Seinfeld episode your date
is a close talker oh my God I can't I
can't no I can't immediately no I mean
it depends yeah right and are we
attracted to this person
context contract dealer's Choice okay
all right
a lot but I think I'm gonna stick to
this I I I I say no okay all right
um your date enjoys pineapple on their
Pizza
[Applause]
is so judgment yeah
stick all right I love pineapple on
myself it's so delicious all right well
this one goes back to a much more
divisive question your date's mom still
does their laundry for them oh man no no
no no no no no yeah you gotta go yeah
I'm so sorry
that's a no that's over with
um all right really quickly round robin
um biggest deal breaker for you being
rude to a waiter agreed oh my god
um being rude to an unhoused person yeah
um talking over me
um I feel like it would probably be just
like I can always tell when somebody's
listening to me just to listen and
they're not really hearing me and I
really value being heard so like an
active listener who's not doing it for
themselves number one thing you're all
looking for number one thing that is
like your ultimate green flag go someone
who has done enough work on themselves
who's astute enough to like realize what
things are that they've gone through
that they're and even if still doing it
they know what they are back in progress
a conscious person trying to be a better
person all the time appreciates Humanity
loves people is a loving person yeah oh
wow
people who are loyal people don't switch
up I really value that
yeah um I like to laugh I like to laugh
and yeah I need you to like make me
laugh a jokey joke yeah anyone with a
job and a sense of humor is going to be
a great start yeah
thank you Renee rap I'm Rick Carr
Pauline chalamet and Aaliyah Chanel
Scott I cannot thank you guys Enough
season two the sex lives of college
girls drops on HBO Max Thursday November
17th I'll be all caught up by then okay
what's today's national holiday I'll
give you a small and delicious hint
we're gonna find out what what's
happened after the break whatever
foreign
[Music]